A very warm welcome to the Goal Setting Module. Setting Goals is long been known as a very
powerful tool to help your clarity, your focus, to help companies have their focus, have teams
have focus and to really know what you're putting your energies and collective energies
into. All kinds of people at operating high levels love setting goals. And in this module
we're going to explore two primary ways to do that. It's the 90 day goal setting. That's
the bigger picture and we're going to do a walkthrough that's giving you an idea of how
that's happening. And then we're going to look at the top five goals that we set for
the week. Coming right up after this video is an animation that's just going to share
a little bit about goals. Again, that was produced for athletes. Enjoy the animation.
And then we're going to come back and go through the deep dive after the animation of the 90
day goals first and then the top five second and then I'll join you at the very end just
to summarize it all. Enjoy.